back pain is one of the biggest reasons
we seek medical care and low back pain
is listed as a leading cause of
disability worldwide but there's a lot
of misinformation out there and along
with it a lot of bad treatments
[Music]
so today I want to bring up five things
you should know about back pain one back
pain isn't just limited to the spine our
back is made of Bones called vertebrae
that run from your neck to your tailbone
these vertebrae form the spinal column
which houses the spinal cord each
vertebrae is also connected to the
others by ligaments between each
vertebrae are discs which provide
cushion and help absorb and distribute
pressure within this structure of
connections are also joints muscles
tendons and nerves but our back isn't
held up by just the spine in fact a lot
of that work is done by our core which
includes our abdominal muscles low back
muscles hips and glutes and pelvic floor
the muscles in our core take pressure
off the rest of the spine every day we
put all kinds of pressure on our backs
when we walk stand carry our groceries
lift boxes and even when we sit so it's
not only spinal pressure but torn
muscles or slipped that could be
contributing to back pain but pain
itself is even more complex often it's
how pain signals are processed in the
nerves or in the brain that perpetuates
the pain other factors like Stress and
Anxiety can amplify pain this complexity
is why treating back pain can be so
frustrating and why it's enticing to
seek out all sorts of medically suspect
care which leads me to two chiropractic
treatment is not backed by science going
to chiropractors for spinal manipulation
is very popular especially in the United
States but a study that looked at 45
systematic reviews found no evidence
supporting chiropractic treatment as
effective for any medical condition I'm
not denying that people who visit
chiropractors sometimes feel better
after a session but studies suggest that
the comfort and relief from being
touched is most likely a placebo effect
this is also a reminder that
chiropractor practic treatment can
sometimes be dangerous there are people
who have suffered vascular Strokes after
neck adjustments three Imaging
techniques like MRI or x-ray don't
always help with diagnosing back pain
for instance you can be in a lot of pain
and get an MRI showing a pristine spine
with nothing out of the ordinary or you
could have no pain whatsoever and an MRI
could turn up abnormalities like a
bulging disc and what's more sometimes
when you do have pain and abnormality on
MRI may have nothing to do with it
additionally an MRI doesn't always
capture what's happening with your
muscles or tell us how pain is being
processed in the brain there are
instances when Imaging helps to allow a
serious problem especially after trauma
or an accident or if there are red flags
meaning warning signs for cancer or
troubling neurological symptoms but for
the majority of people with back pain
imaging has actually been associated
with worse patient outcomes and
unnecessary surgeries speaking of
surgeries 4. back surgeries can
sometimes do more harm than good
researchers analyze studies on two types
of spine surgery lumbar spine fusion and
lumbar spine decompression they found
that neither of these surgeries was more
effective than non-surgical treatment
which I'll get into in a bit finally
five physical therapy is a really good
option for back pain a well-designed
physical therapy program can often be
very effective at treating acute and
chronic back pain but it does take work
good Physical Therapy involves not just
assessments but also a structured home
exercise program which you need to do
regularly there are also
multi-disciplinary clinics that can
offer multimodal therapy like
medications physical therapy and
sometimes injections what I'm saying is
this there isn't always an easy sticks
for back pain the solutions take time
and sometimes need a multi-pronged
approach for now you can show your back
some love by staying active and doing
exercises that strengthen your muscles
including your core